the justice department is filing
criminal charges against more than a
dozen people from florida to california
in a series of medicare scams
that exploited coronavirus fears to
build tens of millions of dollars in
bogus claims
a common hook involved a pandemic
variant of identity theft
fraudsters allegedly offered covert 19
tests
to get the medicare numbers of
unsuspecting patients
then they used that information to bill
for lucrative but
unneeded genetic tests that can cost
thousands of dollars
an american veteran a marine now engaged
in another kind of
fight for the freedom of north korea is
in legal jeopardy tonight
and also tonight some who know what he's
facing
worry his life may also be in danger
senior correspondent eric shaun has
details
he is a u.s marine who could be executed
by kim jong-un
say his supporters if the biden
administration continues to try and
extradite him
christopher ahn who served in iraq faces
charges in spain that he broke into the
north korean embassy in madrid
two years ago and spanish authorities
want him back
they've told me that that danger is here
in the united states
and that that that danger exponentially
increases
if i leave the country and the same the
same
department of justice that's told me
that if i leave the country that i could
be assassinated
is the same department of justice that's
trying to extradite me
so yes i mean the the fear is there
chris says he was invited in as part of
a plan by his anti-regime activist group
free joson or free north korea to help
kim jong-un's ambassador to spain
defect but the diplomat changed his mind
they may be north korean but they're
parents and and
they love their children and and they've
been fed lies their entire life
and they come to a western country and
they realize
that everything that they've been told
are lies
at court to show their support the
parents of otto warmbier
the 22 year old college student falsely
arrested
tortured and sent home to die by kim's
regime in 2017
in an emotional plea that brought
spectators to tears
mrs warmbier told the court quote no one
ever stands up to north korea
well i am standing up to north korea i
am standing up
for chris on a good man the u.s
government is trying to
extradite me and it's very disappointing
that that's what they want to do quite
frankly
but i also have trust in the american
government i have trust in the american
system
and quite frankly i have trust in the
american people
well the u.s magistrate gene rosenbluth
is expected to issue a decision
on on's extradition sometime in the next
few weeks
brett eric thanks we'll follow it hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else